hi everyone
how are you
our executive producer our uh our
main man jason kurtz has the saying all
the feels
did everyone have all the feels this
holiday
all the fields i thought about opening
up the show at one point like
like this i felt so many things this
holiday
i really did uh but ultimately it was a
good one
and hopefully a safe one and a happy one
and did everybody here the best crew in
the world
all i kept thinking was nobody have
people from out of town
we want to keep doing the show
i know i was like solo by myself and a
body condom it was amazing
um
[Laughter]
one thing that did happen that i'm so
excited about
is that this holiday season i was
inspired to try and do a gift guide so i
looked around and i have my little
yellow book
that i do every week i love sharing
stuff as if we need more stuff but i'm
just like stuff stuff stuff that helps
us in our lives stuff that's delightful
beautiful you know progressive things
that actually
work is all i ever want to share so i
was trying to put together a gift guide
and then i was like
why am i doing this what's important
here and
i realized that small business was what
i wanted to focus on
so we put out a thing on instagram we
got all these submissions back
seventy thousand we are narrowing it
down we launched with five
um we're going to come out with five
more this week it takes a lot to go into
it legally you have to go through all
this stuff i found out oprah starts
doing her gift guide in january
i now see why um and i mean january the
year before
um so now we officially have launched
this little
it's drew's little book of small
business gift guide
and it features small businesses from
from across the country we
i have video and footage i'll show of me
like going through each and every one it
took
teams of people and now we're going to
launch our next fight so we'll have 10
probably 15 or 20 by the time we're done
with the year and we're gonna carry it
through there's valentine's day
there's birthdays there's all of these
things where we need to promote these
businesses so
our five are up and at the beginning of
our list of five that are going to come
out this week are the owners
featured and they are in boston
they are the first black owned bookstore
in in boston frugal bookstore
please welcome husband and wife duo
leonard and clarissa
hello hi drew hi everyone
oh my goodness i'm so happy to meet you
uh we talked about you on the show when
we were kicking this off
this has been such an important
conversation it's been so
eye-opening so intention
opening so expansive to the horizons of
my own
small little life how important this
conversation
is and how much it sparked people around
the country
and why did you begin a small business
you love books you're a husband and wife
how did frugal bookstores come about
yeah so we leonard and i both uh we grew
up in the area
and we uh are both avid readers and
we've always had a
love of reading uh and we knew that uh
you know books can take you anywhere and
so we knew that at some point
uh books would be in our future and my
love for books came from when i was
younger my mother
was going to college at night and she
didn't have any child care so she used
to tag me along with her
and the only thing that kept me quiet
was to put a book in my hand
that's how i started reading well
my goodness she was a good mom taking
you with her to work
and it's true you can go anywhere with
books they're the most
empowering tool i feel like humans have
created
i mean they're historical geographical
fantastical literary there's nothing you
can't really get
from a book transportive that's a
wonderful
story i really relate to that i think
books were my personal
education when i was like 14 i realized
oh my god i've got to go to school i
didn't go to school i was working on
movies and
books were my way in to self-education
and
may i ask you what makes you the most
proud
of your bookstore well
it started out in a niche of another
store furniture store
and now it became a standalone bookstore
and like 98
of the books are by authors of color
when you walk in it's just
so colorful and beautiful it's it's it's
amazing to see
that many um black and brown faces on
books
right and you know our our bookstore
is uh a place of gathering it's a place
for culture
and community uh our customers come here
to network they run into each other
we've seen children grow up in our
bookstore
uh just this past weekend we had someone
say i remember when i was a little
you know when i was a child my my
parents brought me to your bookstore so
uh to see you know young people grow up
and uh who grew up in our bookstore
reading our books is
just an awesome thing it truly is a
blessing
well there's a whole circle of life from
you being a child leonard
and growing up with books and now
children are in your and clarissa's
store
growing up themselves and for more
information on frugal bookstore and our
entire
little book of small businesses gift
guide head over to the
show.com leonard and clarissa i'm
honored to kick this week off with you
and thank you so much for coming to the
show and telling us everything you just
did
thanks for having us
i grew up with you on the screen so
thank you i love you
well thank you so much and i'm actually
going to be purchasing some books for
your
from your store because i'm now also
going to buy all of my christmas
presents
from all the businesses that we've
discovered
and so that's another way i can
participate so
i look forward to making some purchases
with you this month
as gifts for other people so thank you
don't forget today
is cyber monday oh don't i know it
believe me i've been like i've got a
whole plan
and uh so everybody go to frugal
bookstores and go boston by the way
so thank you leonard and clarissa we
will see you soon